the true meltdown of the day was not
over on msnbc it was over on cnn
so nancy pelosi has been holding up the
stimulus package republicans have
proposed 1.8 trillion dollars in new
spending
to stimulate people who have been hurt
by the lockdown
because again when the government forces
you not to do your business
well then the government has taken
something from you and they ought to
compensate you this is the fifth
amendment the takings clause
even democrats have been slamming nancy
pelosi for her unwillingness
to take any sort of deal andrew yang
over the weekend
tweeted at her and he told pelosi to
take the deal or risk political fallout
he said put politics aside
people are hurting former obama
administration official dan pfeiffer
agreed
telling pelosi to ignore potential risk
and just inked the deal said democrats
should aggressively pursue a covered
relief deal
with trump is according to emily zenati
over at daily wire
he said it's the right thing to do but
the politics can also work in our favor
even representative rocanna
who's very far to the left like bernie
sanders leftist suggested that a
stimulus package would be
a good idea okay so she was asked about
this by wolf blitzer on cnn
how unused to criticism is nancy pelosi
when she is asked a simple question by
wolf blitzer she loses her damned mind
she starts to look like the the bad guys
at the end of raiders of the lost ark
where their faces melt off i mean she
just
lost it she called she called him a
republican apologist
i mean this was a crazy off the rails
interview and if she weren't a democrat
everybody would be
this is the brilliant strategist we have
all been told is the is the mistress of
our imagination here was
nancy pelosi melting down on wolf
blitzer of all people
excuse me for interrupting thanksgiving
madam speaker but they really need the
money right now
uh and even members of i have said that
but if but even members of your own
caucuses
members of your own caucus madam speaker
uh want to accept this deal 1.8 trillion
dollars so what do you say to ro khanna
what i say to you is i don't know why
you're always an apologist
and many of your colleagues apologize
for the republican position
rolcana that's nice that isn't what
we're going to do
okay wolf blitzer is here an apologist
for the republicans
really wolff blitzer and cnn these are
the
you know how wildly leftist and in your
bubble you have to believe you have to
be to believe that wolf
blitzer is an apologist for the
republicans it got worse by the way
nancy pelosi
just like if trump had done this to any
member of the media be this is a threat
to the free press
how dare anybody treat a member of our
beloved journalistic establishment like
this this is just terrible
the president only wants his name on a
check to go out before election day
and for the market to go up is that what
this is all about
not allow the president to take credit
if there's a deal that will help
millions of americans
right now he's not that important but
let me say this
with all due respect with all due
respect and you know we've known each
other a long time
you really don't know what you're
talking about oh that was
there's a lot of due respect there i
felt the respect did you feel all the
respect there
with all due respect with all due
respect you're an ass
she's lost her mind my goodness my
goodness this is i got one but this is
14 minutes long is 14 minutes of pure
pain
in the octagon she got even more
unhinged here she was
do you have any idea of how that's
precisely
right now yesterday i spoke to andrew
yang who says the same thing it's not
everything you want
you know there's a lot there honest to
god
you really uh i can't get over it i
didn't come over here to have
you so you're the apologist for the
obama and
excuse me god forbid madam speaker
apologist i'm asking you serious
questions because so many people
are in desperate news right now let me
ask you this
that was the last time let me respond to
you
uh unbelievable okay and then it
concluded with her saying to wolf
blitzer
i feed poor people what from your twenty
thousand dollar sub zero fridge with
your 13
pints custom-made gelato nancy
that's how you're feeding the poor
here's nancy pelosi talking about i
feed the poor people let them eat cake
literally we're talking about how you're
not feeding the poor people
that's literally the topic of
conversation is why won't you just sign
a 1.8 trillion deal to give people money
in the middle of the greatest lockdown
in modern american history
and she's like i feed poor people i feed
poor people
nothing here is nancy pelosi concluding
this brilliant
interview with wolf blitz remember this
is the most brilliant strategist of our
time we've been told
no you know them i'm i'm just saying i
represent them and we know them
as we say i know them we represent them
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good as they say nowhere near perv
madam speaker always the case but we're
not even close to the good
all right let's see what happens because
every day is critically critically
important thanks so much for joining us
sensitivity to our constituents needs
i am sensitive to them because i see
them on the street begging for food
begging for money not a speaker thank
you we feed them
we feed them well no you don't i feed
them and here's a here's a 13
a 13 pint of ice cream a poor person
that's incredible stuff how do you know
somebody's been in the bubble too long
that's how you know somebody's been in
the bubble too long when wolf blitzer
is owning you in an exchange you've been
in the bubble a little little bit too
long
wild stuff but that media bubble is
extraordinary my mini bubble is
incredible if you enjoyed this video be
sure to hit the thumbs up button and
share it with all of your friends